è il gol che cos'è google stadio dice
wikipedia google stadi è un servizio in
streaming di video giochi sviluppato da
google pubblicato il 19 novembre 2019 è
stato presentato al game developer's
conference il 19 marzo 2019
tanti ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovo
video io sono parigi oggi parliamo di
una nuova console che mi è arrivata c'è
anche scritto il mio nome bellissimo che
sia la google stadio ed eli google credo
siccome quindi google mi ha fatto anche
questa scatola incredibile con il nome
poi ci faremo il primo gameplay insomma
di google sta riaperte starla perché io
ancora non l'ho provata e vedremo
innanzitutto come è fatta ma prima
ovviamente dobbiamo de scatola rlo
quindi ragazzi ora che abbiamo il
controller eno e concas ultra adesso che
sappiamo tutto quanto possiamo
connettere il nostro concas punto che ci
permette di giocare in 4k a 60 fps sul
nostro televisore e proviamo google
stadio
siccome i ragazzi si può giocare su più
dispositivi in questo caso la
televisione ma c'è anche il computer
portatile al computer fisso che
proveremo durante questo gameplay ogni
giro di circuito devo cambiare ha
comunque dispositivo iniziamo con la tv
per riuscire ad arrivare almeno tra i
primi dieci almeno questo è l'obiettivo
non sono sicuro di raggiungerlo ma
proviamo ragazzi io sono una macchina
la cosa facile visto gioco e guidare non
è vero non lo è per niente perché non
sono in grado di guidare ma per
accogliere
molto presto quarto o quinto fantastico
grazie a questo mi ha fatto stessa cosa
i ragazzi non proprio un gioco di
mattino dovuto scegliere va bene
comunque dirvi ragazzi che se volete
provare staglia teoricamente è
disponibile per tutti quanti un
pacchetto signor stajan premier mi sono
scaduto si chiama ragazzi stati a
premier edition e gli permette di avere
cronica sul tra qui quello che io ho il
controller d'italia quello che volete io
adesso però anche un gradino delle
persone carine che vi vengono addosso
con la macchina potete giocare appunto
in 4k a 60 fps esiste il l'abbonamento
che si chiama italian cup h non si
chiama state poche volte si chiama
italia proprio chi permette di avere tre
mesi gratuiti ogni tot c'è un gioco
gratuito il primo è destinato sempre del
grid
cercate di fare meglio di me siamo ci
siamo ci siamo ci siamo secondo giro che
i ragazzi cambia impostazione fatto di
là per i miei tre chilometri di casa per
arrivare qua ci ho messo un sacco
controller collegato kamoun ok ci siamo
l'obiettivo di sterzo modificato
chissenefrega riprendi ok ma era nera la
macchina
aiuto sbagliato stato dato solo indietro
ce l'ha fatta
ho ripreso ho ripreso decentemente
praticamente ragazzi da pc si può
giocare anche con mouse e tastiera in
questo caso sarebbe un po meglio visto
come guido però sono una persona pigra è
un gioco con joystick e anche qua per te
molto sono sono quindicesimo contenitori
vari 10 perdendo grafica porca porca
vacca lo sapevo è meraviglioso
no porca vacca perché esiste ma inizio
sei posizioni non ci avrò mai ragazzi
impossibile che io ai giochi di macchine
però il portavoce dal tipo red dead
redemption che sarà proprio dissenso ma
fa niente per quanto sono indietro
rispetto agli altri tantissimi ultimo
giro devo cambiare prestazione via
maledizione
ci siamo continua maledizione sono
incastrati 9 fare il cambio è stato
molto difficile ragazzi già non so
guidare normalmente ci manca solo di
dover fare il cambio sul letto
ci sono impedimenti il mio letto si
rivolta contro contro di me
aiuto aiuto aiuto
riesco più a giocare ma edizione a danno
irreversibile sì ha letto che alla
macchina
quindi ragazzi il nuovo giro proviamo a
vedere se scaffali media di prima almeno
non essere distrutto da il caos si fa
benissimo ma la macchina rossa quindi
praticamente doveva andarci velocità del
più veloce delle altre non funziona così
money money money money money money
bellissima correlava bene sono primo chi
portato essere prima di togliere ci devi
togliere primo primo primo non
sinceramente nella mia vita la portata
arrivare tra i primi dieci quindi già
essere primo è a posto non durerà a
niente questo primo questa prima
posizione prova niente felice anche un
controllo per
avere il browser è comunque lo sapevo
che la prima posizione sarebbe durata
veramente poco però terza va ancora bene
ragazzi
ok bellissima curva molto bene ma era
sul secondo tiro 2 devo cambiare pò
station le stock siamo ok c'è in cielo
ci siamo riprendi ok
insomma secondo attenzione
mentre nella posizione guardava reggono
cambiato costruzione coniglio di
prendere un altro
perfetto agio con dio
mamma mia quanto mai staccato il primo
il primo c'è un po rock cast mega ultrà
sono quasi primo sono questi prima
dell'inizio iniziano l'edizione let's go
pingi sull'acceleratore maledizione che
macchina studio ecco lo farò ma no dai
basta però io ho giocato bene ragazzi
cioè era sportivo secondo me andare
contro la macchina se c'è questa regola
puoi farli ho fatto dai ragazzi mi sono
divertito anche se mi sono schiantato
due volte e stata una bella guida
spero vogliate meglio di me mi è
piaciuta molto stati anche se
effettivamente non so guidare ma quello
è un altro problema che va beh va beh
ragazzi prima o poi lo so che lo
ricordiamo suo problema basta basta
basta e schiantarsi con le macchine
basta però se prendete staglia nel 2020
c'è anche la versione base è dove potete
comprare il gioco è giocare direttamente
se prendete grigie falcor di dio cercate
di non schiantarmi e niente ragazzi
mettetevi piace viso iscrivetevi al
canale schiacciatela campanellina per
rimanere aggiornati sul mio video desco
e non è come sempre ci vediamo al
seguito per telecomando beh ragazzi
[Musica]